Chinese agents in the U.S accused of
intimidating critics of China's
government two men under arrest this
morning accused of opening and running a
secret Chinese police station in New
York City Jeff begaze has this story
down building in
[Music]
according to investigators it was run
y's government to track and even harass
dissidents living here in the U.S this
case is a further example of the
audacious activities that the government
of China has carried out right here on
American soil Breon peace the U.S
attorney for the eastern district of New
York says officers from China's Ministry
of public security or MPS were operating
illegally the MPS subjected Chinese
dissidents living here in the United
States to the authoritarian rule of the
PRC
that is unacceptable two men both New
York City residents have been charged
with conspiring to act as agents of
China's government 34 MPS officers have
also been charged with operating an
online troll Farm to threaten Chinese
dissidents in the U.S and to spread
propaganda to sow divisions in the
country what investigators uncovered is
part of a pattern across the world we
found these stations in over 50
countries where people are being
pressured where people are being
threatened where people are being
harassed and intimidated
the suspects arrested are facing some
serious time Behind Bars 20 years if
convicted and as unusual as this case is
you can expect to see more china-related
cases because currently U.S officials
tell us that China poses the most
serious national security threat to the
U.S Gail
boy Jeff it sounds like a movie or a spy
novel thank you very much